all right welcome to game time
with uh grandpa lex i'm not sure if it's
the views of anyone but this is a
record of my brief travels to the year
in the cyberpunk universe i sadly don't
have time to play games these days but
they've been a source of a lot of
pleasure throughout my life so
life's too short might as well enjoy it
every once in a while
i'll try to do this once or twice a
month but if we're being honest
2021 is looking quite insane the next
one i want to try is stanley parable
which is the opposite of cyberpunk
it's only like a 15-minute game that you
played through several times
i think cyberpunk 2077 is supposed to be
a game you could play
if you do all the side quests you should
be able to play for
at least 100 hours so i'm only gonna do
about two
three maybe four hours today and that's
it i'm gonna walk away
nobody walks away from a good rpg well
i'm gonna walk away friends it's called
discipline
all right here we go oh and uh please
check out our sponsors
in the description theragon and
grammarly
so one is for your muscles and the
others for your grammar
the choice is yours my friends choose
wisely
please check them out in the description
to get a discount and to support the
podcast that i host
all right here we go new game cyberpunk
released just like a couple hours ago
let's go select difficulty level
most things in life i would go very hard
for me normal is probably the equivalent
of what very hard is for most gamers i
really haven't played video games in a
long long time
all right normal's enemies will have all
the tools at their disposal to take v
on v is the name of the character i
suppose but primarily only enemies at a
higher level would prove a challenge
easy as the right choice for players who
just want to sit back and enjoy the
story
combat will not pose a challenge ooh
as you get older you learn to appreciate
the story not the combat
what would david goggins do david
goggins probably go very hard and lose
within five minutes and then go run okay
let's go normal
nomad street kid or corporal so many
decisions
select these life paths some events and
dialogue options in the game will be
different depending on your choice
nomad is roaming the badlands looting
scrape yards reuting fuel depots life on
the road wasn't easy
but growing up in nomad clan has its
perks
honesty integrity and a love of freedom
qualities that few and night city
possess and no amount of money can buy
i like these guys nomads street kids
they say if you want to understand the
streets you got to live them
gangs fixtures dolls small time pushers
you're raised by them all down here the
law of the jungle dictates
the weak serve the strong the only law
in night city you have yet to break
the weak serve the strong i think we're
gonna need a couple hours to think about
that one
okay corpo corporate
comes with a marketing team in hr
if you leave the corporate world with
their lives few are still
with their souls intact amen
you've been there you've bent the rules
exploited secrets and weaponized
information
there's no such thing as a fair game
only winners
and losers i'm pretty sure nomad is
basically where it's at
i wish you could wear a suit and tie as
a nomad let's see if let's see if you
can dress yourself
let's go nomad
oh boy select these body type
these appearance may sometimes affect
the behavior or other characters
appearance doesn't matter it's all about
the inside i feel very uncomfortable
with the selection
so there's this guy with a shortcut and
some red hair
guys with some scars scars are always
good means you've lived
hmm this guy's too good looking
oh this is random generation
all right let's just keep generating
random ones until we get close to what
we're looking for
we want gritty but not too pretty
disturb the comfortable nice tattoo i
think the random generation is
really off i think this is actually
pretty close to what i'm looking for
voice tone masculine
[Music]
feminine
there's pronouns i'm gonna go with he
him skin type
that's so cool
i love video games so much you can
define so much about the characters
hairstyles
oh man let's go with the basics i'm a
big fan of eyes so i think
eyes truly are the window to the soul so
let's see
oh it's like interesting it's more like
the entirety of the structure of the
okay cool i like the intensity of the
original guy
eyebrows
whatever this is good enough it's
starting to get uncomfortable
nose that's good enough mouth
yep ears can you call
cauliflower ears
this guy been in a fight come on
give me some is this is that is that a
how far
[Music]
do we really need 21 ear types beard
beard is fine maybe clean shaven nah
cyberware
i don't know can you go and know
it's kind of old-school with this yeah a
little subtlety
yeah just off okay yeah
off on the cyberware we go old school
we like cyber but let's keep it off the
face
not the face facial scars yeah you gotta
have facial scars
each one of them has a whoa that's
that's intense
that's like a tire been driven over him
i like i like uh
i like this one it's got hit in the head
with something
facial tattoos nah piercings nah
teeth yes please
oh yeah i'll go with the white ones oh
right yeah
basic teeth eye makeup color
lip makeup cheek makeup
blemishes nails short
uh nipples on or off
you can turn off the nipples let's keep
the nipples
body tattoos bodies no tattoos
scars yes
let's go with the bruce lee the three
the three scratch marks
that's either a cat or overly friendly
girlfriend
genitals i'll probably edit that part
out but you can actually select the
genitals
so like penis or vagina and then you can
select the penis size
and the pubic hair style it's kind of
fascinating it's an interesting design
choice
but since i'm thinking of uploading this
video i'll keep it family friendly
but in case you're wondering uh this
character is packing some heat
uh customize attributes choose the core
attributes you want to begin with
each attribute contains a set of skills
both attributes and skills provide
different bonuses depending on your
style of play
skill levels increases you perform
activities associated with them
the maximum level of a skill is limited
by the level of the attribute that it
belongs to
interesting
body determines your raw physical power
okay
intelligence determines your net running
proficiency
every level of intelligence will
increase cyber deck ram capacity
increase quick hack damage basically
hacking ability
so computer skills segment pulling
dynamite non-check skills
reflexes determine your maneuverability
technical ability represents your
technical
know-how it allows you to unlock doors
and use tech
weapons cool determines your resilience
composure and effectiveness and
operating from stealth
so like a stealthy type of thing
so intelligence is like the that's the
mage
the wizard bodies like the warrior
reflexes yeah it's like agility
technical ability that's pick lock
picking
and then cool is like stealth like in
this looking in the shadow
probably i probably go body and
intelligence probably emphasizing
intelligence
so i gotta be honest with you i'm not
into lock baking or sneaking around
i'm uh slow hit hard
but also have uh reasonably okay
programming ability so probably gonna
put everything into
body and intelligence well
irl and since it looks like i can't
spend everything on body and
intelligence
ain't that the truth i'll go one in
reflexes
so begins your story night city alias v
backstory nomad attributes
we know what the attributes are there's
the scan code for the biometric data
let's go
user unknown patch f
remove patch
i backers it was nothing serious when i
came in you said you were sure
move with can always wsad and look
around with the mouse
that mechanic looks like a punk
maybe i should look in the mirror so how
do i actually engage with them
you can cycle through dialogue choices i
guess with the mouse wheel
or up up and down calm down brother
okay so now in square brackets there's
check engine and i can tell them to step
aside i'll handle it
or uh i'm going to pay you what we
agreed
i'm gonna pay you what we agreed i'm
gonna pay you what we agreed
not one anymore huh for that you can
borrow my tools and fix it yourself
all right that's fine step aside
what you heard any idea what to do
i think i'll bypass the coupling i'm
going to bypass the coupling and rig a
hot wire
compressor will run on and on
i know what i'm doing did you
ask your opinion i like this guy's
opinion
satan maids of satan
uh so the exclamation point says get in
the car
so those are the things like those are
like quests or instructions get in
f cool let's go
okay let's see what happens
start engine
not shabby at all i love the sound of
this car
and it'll get me to night city i figure
something else out there
connect a radio station yes
on this heap don't please like it packs
a punch not liable to him much
you don't say
hey mike didn't know you had a customer
i rolled in a few hours passed i
i thought he'd at least called in don't
you swear to mine
we're gonna hash it out i like this town
don't you know you owe the sheriff a
word when you pay his town a visit
to tell him what's brought you here hey
big guy
i'm just passing through no need to
worry i won't be staying long
didn't answer my question now did you
i'm here alone i travel alone there is
no clan there is no camp
i'm here alone closed door i don't want
any trouble
i don't think i want any trouble not
afraid of it just don't want trouble
with this guy
he seems like a small fish i don't want
any trouble
then stop looking for her and hit the
roof all right calm down buddy
drive out the garage w
vehicle steering a and d accelerator w
brake with us
cool and where do i go
go to the telecom tower okay gotcha
such a boomer active job objectives are
marked with the exclamation
on the hud okay go to the telecom tower
oh man video games are so fun
you drunk legs go home
so bad at this
sorry i'm i'm paying attention to a
million things that's the
i'm not paying attention to the road
[Music]
next vehicle dug the vehicle hold f
this game is so beautiful
i want to go hiking out there can we
just go that is that a side quest just
go hiking
oh this is nice it's freezing in boston
right now this would be nice
just running up that mountain you see
like uh david goggins
running along those mountains look how
beautiful that is
that's when you know you're getting old
you don't want to shoot anything you
just want to enjoy
walking around looking at the beautiful
scenery all right
f enter what do you what do you want
from me
kick it in you gotta kick it in
climb the telecom tower and locate the
control box
hopefully this is not nauseating to to
watch
let's see so how do you oh cool
very rusty with this whole video game
thing
open oh that's not the button
i'm also using a kinesis keyboard which
is really hard to press stuff with
connect to radio
this is ground control to major tom come
in
come in raised to finally
willie mccoy it's good to hear your
voice
fee wish i could say the same
[Music]
i need your help i need your help
look at that last time look at that car
driving last time
again yes i have to find the client with
my payload
but i don't know where he is
right place right time you were there
of course of course i was
maybe the client left a message could
you check for me
hmm sure
last time though i mean it client's name
jackie wells
actually left a message he's waiting on
a farm
flicking you the globe data cool thanks
willie i owe you one
this this is the keanu reeves character
i think get yourself killed
don't get yourself killed don't call
again
wow that sounds like every time i talk
to my parents
i'm terrified of heights even in a video
game so
this is very stressful
look at this thing definitely not a
tesla
maybe a cyber truck like a really
beat up cyber truck
i love that sound head to the meeting
place
[Music]
wow what how old are you that you're
driving like this
it's hard with the kinesis keyboard
that's my excuse
plus i don't want to go slowly you want
to go fast
so soon this is jacques valjean i
all i was doing is driving sir okay
police introduction
any illegal activity such as theft or
attacking civilians
will result in an ncpd placing a bounty
on you the police will send a patrol
to the crime scene and the strength of
the response will be proportional to the
sus the penalty to lose
the police move away from the crime
scene and lay low for a while
so it's kind of like gta grand theft
auto
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm really sorry i was just
driving sir
they're shooting at me i should've gone
with the easy level
i just wanted to go hiking
this is so bad it's really sensitive
okay in uh
in meet space i'm used to the car not
being so sensitive to my keyboard
i'm gonna head to the meeting place i
don't know any of the keyboard shortcuts
of how to like look behind me
get out of the car this is very
stressful
f i'm getting out of the car he told me
to get out of the car
getting out of the car are you
oh you have to hold f cool me jackie
wells
all right kiana let's go where you at
oh i was worried i'd have to turn to
farming okay i guess this is not the
the cannery's character
are you jackie wells are you wells
and jackie i'm v
it seems you have cargo that needs to be
moved
oh where i'm from you share a bit about
your soul before you talk biz
good man it's kind of like a custom man
let's do a podcast just good manners you
know
let's start with you then why don't we
start with you then
nc native right here got haywood in my
blood
i've never been to nc that doesn't mean
much to me
so imagine a place where everyone's like
your bro or sis
or family cousin at least i think i
understand
you don't have to like each other but
it's family that's he would
that and everyone's packing iron
it's like the futuristic version of
godfather you could say i'm from my own
haywood
you are mysterious we're gonna get along
fine
what's with the cargo the haircut choice
i'm questioning it
what's inside don't ask questions let's
just load it up let's load it in the car
oh it will
follow jackie how much you think this
guy can bench might not come
i got held up and you weren't exactly
easy to find
probably does uh i need to lay low you
know 315.
reps of 10. grouchy [ __ ]
that's not nice no swearing please open
the trunk
i should have passed what's in there
i'm starting to regret these decisions
here we go again i'm just going to go
the speed limit this time
[Music]
couldn't get made fun of so much for
this driving
[Music]
back in my day we used to play prince of
persia
didn't give you the job deeds exist in a
two-dimensional world
i was just scrolling from left to
we're more right are we
this is such a beautiful game i look at
the city in the background
sure you've moved contraband before why
are you nervous
me
look at this world it feels like a
coronavirus time too
deserted the wind is blowing i love this
drive to the border
[Music]
the police officers they're always nice
please direct your vehicle to the
inspection area
i think that was just remain in your
vehicle the security check will begin
shortly i got a real bad feeling about
this
take document hand me the fan have me
the manifest don't need to see it
grab these let me see
it's marked loa perfect what's that mean
lost on arrival it means the cargo's
flagged us to be lost as soon as you
cross the border
so they know we're smuggling they're
about to find out
look at the dog bobblehead
customs officer to turn a blind eye to
our dubious docus will need a sweetener
do you have the credit chip with the
bribe oh
yeah forgot about that
oh interesting is it bitcoin or is it
ethereum
take money get out right
you forgot
deposit weapon at the front desk
i don't know if i'm armed place weapon
now i know wow that thing looks good
now please report to room number two to
one of my favorite numbers keep pressing
the wrong key
that'd be funny if he was wearing a make
america great again hat
papers
is this routine this routine it might be
we'll see
i like the depth of conversation here
what are you transporting i don't know
in there
ah yes remind me you drive for which
nomad clan
i don't drive for any clan none no clan
i drive for myself
bold and none too wise
you know what man whenever i see someone
like you i'm oh so grateful not to be on
that side of the table
i feel the same way go on now
your associate's waiting for you in the
car
collect your weapon at the front desk i
apologize if i'm moving really slowly
here
i'm just enjoying this this is super fun
for me
just walking around like each of these
people have a life story probably
and welcome to night city thank you
those little shits imagine night city is
some kind of paradise
turn to the car oh he's driving i guess
soon
we need to get out of here yeah okay
for a guy that looks like that on first
appearance he seems awfully nervous
smelling trouble around the bend drive
jackie just drive
he seemed nervous but he uh someone's
coming our way since their soul
this does not look good tough exterior
sensitive soul
stop your vehicle immediately let's get
out of here
[Music]
you are transporting contraband that is
corporate property
given how bad i was at driving i'm
probably even worse at shooting
damn
draw weapon is alt kinesis keyboard man
oh this is fun to shoot
okay see i gotta actually
am i trying to hit them or the car
i see the car yeah
i thought i hit him in the head and he's
still okay
it's like i guess the game where you hit
the person
that doesn't uh kill them
this is very stressful
i don't like shooting at the police at
this difficult
tense time in 2020
uh i'm a huge supporter of the police
one of the hardest jobs
i apologize for shooting at them
in this artificially destructive world
of 2077.
i'm also realizing my mouth
keep driving you can't stop here
oh there's some cool drones in the air
very interesting place looks deserted
i'm gonna stop here we need to sort out
a few things before we go on
nice
my palms are wet get out of the car
let's go i almost tagged our asses
that what you call smuggling chicado
was supposed to go smooth no problems
temper calm down things like this happen
sometimes these things happen actually i
wasn't gonna pay you at all
it's just gonna bust ass disappear as
soon as we crossed over
but you're all right
i appreciate the honesty appreciate the
honesty yeah
thanks but no what's next
now we take a peek inside oh please
don't be a body
please don't be a body all right let's
look
oh [ __ ] it says arasaka on the crate
we are robbing some heavy hitters maybe
we'll make some heavy money
fish hummus a real iguana a uh
oh lester i think let's talk about
wasn't going
to what yeah what's the thing on tv
about them went extinct like 30 years
ago
from the lesser antilles you come along
jimmy pull it up
oh that thing looks beautiful
sure i think it'll make us happy
no plans i don't have any plans i've
spent the last years traveling between
states with my nomad family
i'll probably be waiting for you
somewhere eh no
we decided to go our separate ways that
must be tough huh
i haven't no one to go back to but don't
you worry
let me help you find dicks you got to
live somewhere
it's important to have people you can
turn to
you know like family maybe you'll find
your own down in night city
thanks much appreciate it hey come on
it's nothing
you got chemistry you and me be a crying
shame to waste it
hope this guy's not trying to trick me
oh that thing's cute look at that
all right let's shake hands okay partner
time to grab that
man scurry out of here
chick we're looking for somewhere in
this building
probably crawling with the pineapples
the kidnapped her
town half a year later speaking of which
got you a little something militech
training shard
in case you need to uh brush up on your
dance moves
all right let's do a little tutorial
let's do a little shooting practice i
guess it is
wait where am i plugging that in what
where did i just plug that in
this is um neural link step attack
to bust ass exciting this fascist
playground
yellow gun not my style we'll have to do
what am i doing shoot all the targets
okay
yeah i didn't think you'd find that too
tough what do you say we crank it up a
notch
wait the next round the targets
that's terrible not bad uh
take standing around
press c to crouch and hide behind cover
cover can protect you from enemy fire
and then undo
oh headshot does matter got it use a
reanimator to patch yourself up
how do you do that you're injured if
your health falls to zero you die
use the inhalation to gain health when
you pick up
a consumable it will automatically be
added to the consumables
quick slot in your inventory if empty
press x now to use one other game
come on don't need you hurt okay cool
head to the training area when you're
good to go where's the health switching
weapons press one two three or four
or the swish weapons
cool i should also say that i haven't
played shooters very much so i'm really
terrible
shooters okay
cool so maybe
framework v stand on the platform and
we'll move
the next item on the menu notice i
tweaked the course material a bit i like
this lady
hacking cool let's begin training
i wonder if she's a robot scanning
highlights objects of interest in your
surroundings it provides valuable
information about them
cool hazards are highlighted in red
hackable objects are highlighted in
green objects useful in other ways are
highlighted
in blue release tab to exit the scanner
cool
work a little magic on the screen to
distract the guard
with the cyber deck installed your
scanner provides an additional interface
for selecting quick hacks and their
targets
use distract enemies to distract the
guard navigate the list of available
quick hacks with
the mouse wheel
duration 30 seconds cooldown 0 seconds
upload time 1.434 seconds
causes the device to malfunction
resulting in erratic behavior that will
distract nearby people
wow so hacking is a big part of this
game that's interesting
and intelligence is a part of hacking so
i'm glad i invested intelligence
not all about brute force
i guess the body helped with the kicking
down the door
this game is cool probably way too
complicated
okay sneak up to the guard got it
good okay now take him out quietly
all right all yours take them out
uh kill of course
never smart to leave behind there's an
alternate reality where murder is
supposedly allowed now pick up the body
and hide it somewhere
uh pick up the body approach it closely
look at it and
hold r sometimes the dirty deed must be
done
you can hide dead and unconscious
enemies in certain places
doing so will help you avoid detection
by other enemies
got it
up off in the dumpster you go i'm sorry
friend
but this is just virtual reality now
try to take them down in one slick move
i want to see what technique he used
time to get down and dirty in close
quarter combat
tap to perform a fast attack hit the
enemy three times with fast attacks got
it
to perform a fast attack combo press
the left mouse button while the previous
fast attack is executed
hold the left mouse button to charge the
strong attack then release it to perform
it
cool let's go
there you go use the techniques you've
learned so far to defeat the enemy
i can't teach you no more this is the
part where you face your final test
[Music]
and here i am using none of the
techniques
grab a sword
nice the melee combat techniques you've
learned can also be used with melee
weapons such as the katana
okay so i can block
cool
cool very easy
good stuff looks like you're cruising
already
she looks proud of me now we can get
down to biz
time to work let's do this
this is such a fun escape from the real
world
unfortunately i probably only got an
hour
maybe two most i guess there's a lot of
pre-story to get through here
i may not even get much at all into the
main quest
yes hi what are you looking at
[Music]
sandra dorsett targets biomon went mute
a couple hours back
suspected abduction jack is right calm
the hell down
could at least try to be nice you want
nice
supportive call a damn helpline
why can't why can't we all just get
along looking for 1237.
he's just yoga working his posture
should be inside but i got zero eyes on
her biomass
fingers crossed it's not too late is
that you oh i hate this
life or death [ __ ] try hacking the door
like you can trip it on your own v
huh that seemed like a nice lady
i know you're a sweetheart inside that
tough exterior
you need to calm down my man
jackie hacked the door to begin hacking
look at a device and scan it by holding
tab
cool open remote deactivation
cool no profile
it's a hostile area
a bunch of stuff
what's happening
that's how i feel like every time i go
to the dentist
[Music]
oh
take one down just real quiet
probably not the last of them
fabric tank top all right it'll take
everything
i'm sorry buddy yeah
let's take the guns
oh this thing is
[Music]
[Applause]
don't see any movement on the sensors
looks like you got them you're clear to
go
find sandra dorset
what's up jackie how you doing brother
we should do a podcast after this oh
there's two of them
[Music]
well
they don't look too friendly
stimulus being administered 70
milligrams dopamine
110 norepinephrine 800
listen mano i got this thing mind if i
borrow your wheels
yeah let's go i got a date with misty
but
i can't take the metro how's it gonna
look for me
she sounds like a nice lady don't get
used to it
how about i drive you home huh she's all
yours
i'm beat as it is ah these cars are
badass
reminds me back to the future
even though this is the future
it sure looks like the 80s
good
i could tell i could probably spend like
a hundred plus hours here just exploring
the city
there's a mix of la there's a mix of
vegas
jackie's deserted locking down watts
come on keep her steady
[Music]
this game so far is a lot more shooting
than rpg
it really gives me the grand theft auto
vibe
you know it's fun but like i said i'm
much more elder scrolls kind of guy
i guess it's a good little experiment
about what it's like to play games to
comment
and so on what is it that makes me so
special
a heart of gold because only somebody
with a heart of gold can understand just
how much i need to get back to my girl
you're a girl i told you jackie's a
sweetheart
romantic i mean
i'm probably cries during a
notebook let us through please
let's see if kindness gets us through
can we just ride with jackie listen to
led zeppelin
and not shoot anybody can we do that
so you can be nice amen
i'm always never not nice
it's pretty good dialogue pretty good
conversation
i like this place i like this game
it's gonna be sad to say goodbye all
right
tell misty i said hi nice handshake
go home ah it's good to be home
this is my apartment this is uh
this is the opposite of what in my
apartment looks like
this is way too nice second sleep check
your weapon stash and then go to bed
all right where's the computer how are
you supposed to do any kind of
programming it's just guns
go to bed let's go to bed
it's actually currently 3
am in boston so it's actually getting
about that time
close to bed act one
okay maybe i'll do one quest and then
i'll be it for this game
it'll be time to say goodbye the
graphics
the characters i could tell i would love
this game
it's a beautiful place to visit
part of me is actually really enjoying
the fact that
i can just see people they're not
wearing masks
we're in proximity we can just explore
the depth that is each other's weirdness
oh man this feels surprisingly good just
to be among people
even if it's in a virtual world
these people are awesome oh man i can't
wait till things open back up and you
can just meet people and talk to people
look at this look at the city wow
wow
took you long enough worked up an
appetite
this is very grand theft auto-ish
what's the job exactly we meant to come
out in one piece
our lord and savior wants to tell you
everything himself face to face
no pressure but system malfunction are
these
part of the game or is this like the
bugs that everyone's talking about
all right let's do it let's see what old
dex has to say
set it up god the graphics even at this
level
i don't have it on ultra i have it on
high wheels and this is
1080p i think still so awesome
look at it you could see like the
freckles on his face
so awesome
you have to stop for pedestrians oh
man i'm down you just [ __ ]
i'm not very good at any of this i
apologize
this car is pretty badass that i know
for sure
dr vector will see you now victor's
clinic
vicky surprise everything
though a common practice cyberware
installation is still a dangerous and
invasive procedure which can only be
performed by qualified specialist
ripper docs those are the future
versions of neurosurgeons i suppose
there are several ripper docs
operating through night city who offer a
variety of different cyberware upgrades
select your desired cybernetic upgrade
from the list and enjoy
your new abilities
this is awesome
this is where the surgery happens all
right what's up buddy
what do i owe the pleasure today last
gig had to jack into a client's neuro
socket
neurosci experiencing migraines
nausea hypersensitivity to bright lights
old kitten caboodle all right kit
we'll sort you out in a flash besides
that
how are things
oh looking to upgrade looking to upgrade
do i want to upgrade chair please
sit down relax
gonna keep me waiting all day
let's go back to standing desk
all right as i sit down in the game i
stand up in real life
it keeps saying system malfunction i
wonder if that's the bugs that we're
talking about
karoshi optics best i've got and should
be about right
under the circumstances so cool he's
gonna upgrade the eyes
that is awesome now jackie i got lasik
surgery by the way
best thing i've ever done all right
let's put it in although i don't really
trust
a neurosurgeon with rolled up sleeve and
uh
sleeve tattoos you perusing shoes while
i scan
let's see what's going on inside
[Laughter]
i wonder if the folks in your link any
of them
play this game and what they think this
is funny cybernetic implants are
mechanical replacements for the organic
parts of your body
they can give you super human-like
abilities which can improve your combat
capability and help you survive in
hazardous conditions
although common practice in 2077 the
installation of cyberware is still an
invasive and sometimes dangerous medical
procedure
only specialists known as ripper docs
are trusted to install
cyberware safely let's continue
ocular systems operating systems
god imagine this is the future this is
what
upgrades look like
of course if it in fact cost money then
of course the elite people
that inherent money will be able to
upgrade themselves and thereby
increasing the gap
between the have and have-nots and it'll
be a bernie sanders type of character
who tries to fight that maybe the future
looks a lot like the present
ocular systems let's go with ocular
systems kashuri optics
zero dollars cool i just installed some
new eyes
hands this is free yeah it's free
cool ballistic co-processor
increase the chance to ricochet shots
with power weapons
directly links the user's optical
implant to the weapon system offering
real-time data tracking
interesting links to i or like directly
to the weapon
wow links the weapon
to your eye skipping the entirety of the
rest of the mess of the human biology
cool i love it all right
mark one like i said decent enough
scanner this is cool
just gives me a little preview of this
world carry on the tops of built-in
external lens disrupter if i didn't have
a million things going on let's stay
here for a few more hours but capture
your face as a blur
no just remember your body will still
show up as crystal clear
good to know this should do the trick
talks to karoshi tech too
i'm ready carve away
let's do this i wonder if they'll show
some show the
the neurosurgery lay that major league
arm of yours right here
just like that thanks
look how crappy the equipment is i can
start cutting
oh man they're gonna show it aren't they
play by play though really doc
makes you sound like a dentist always
going on and on
lights out for a minute all right
that's what lasik felt like it's like
these things are going after your eye
but you gotta trust the robotics there
you gotta trust the equipment
and it worked out beautifully for me
i think it works out really well for
most people see the magic in action
linking you in
you might feel a little discomfort at
first word vision
low contrast glitches
how's it look feel all right to you
yeah better than ever this is fantastic
vic
oh beautiful
scanning people with your optical
cyberware can provide you with a lot of
useful information such as how strong an
enemy might be
cool so this like gave me extra ability
to scan
as a skilled netrunner you can see a
list of
quick hacks which you can use against
your enemies okay well this is all stuff
i already know
it might take you a few seconds to
adjust but
first time's rarely the charm with
anything really
scanner should eventually sync with your
thought processes
and read your intentions
i also inject an ncpd file search
run antenna dude wells you know exactly
what they never did well
okay a database of individuals with
bounties assigned to them is now
available to use
you can identify these wanted persons
with your scanner
since all are wanted dead or alive
the method you use to claim your reward
are entirely up to you
this is a pretty violent world isn't it
i'm not gonna ask what it is thanks
again you're the best
i owe you
go on kid show them what you're made of
and once you hit the big leagues don't
forget where you came from
jackie wells
your heart chakra looks a little out of
whack babe
i can release it for you but you'd have
to watch out for negative energy back to
jackie and avoid mean reds
v yo listen up i talked to dex while you
were in with the doc
heart chakras for you
ain't gonna hop to where he's parked
next to gramsci burgers
okay do my best to talk us up regina
jones
listen i've got this delicate matter
that's why i called you
the number of cyber psycho attacks in
the city is on the rise
now that's probably not news to you but
this issue matters to me
for a few reasons there are people who
say cyberpsychosis can be treated
cyberpsychosis and i know exactly
imagine all the psychological disorders
there are side effects of implants
i'll give you a call let's get in this
car
let's get the job done oh is that dex
yo mr v a pleasure dexter desean in the
flesh
mind if i ask you something right off
the bat nice hand
would you rather live in pieces mr
nobody die
ripe old and smelling slightly of urine
or go down for all times in a blaze of
glory smelling near like posies without
seeing your 30th
this guy's a philosopher
how they remember you that's all that
counts classic
i'd expect nothing less from eager
supple youth
respect let me hear it
what's the job there's this prototype
a buyership to be precise jobs to grab
it
simple cigar
not at all let's get it done
[ __ ] you ain't playing around
got a feeling this could be a start of a
beautiful friendship built on heaps of
eddies
you work this out got a plan two things
first a conundrum with the maelstrom
boys needs active resolving that
second to rendezvous simple klein who
brought us the jobs anxious
she wants to parlay with one of the team
what's the issue needs resolving with
maelstrom got a beef
it's not a shark
the shard thing i wish sure had a little
bit more science about it
protein processing plant got away with
the gear
don't even know alpha fold seven
now see convoy was carrying the flat
head a little combat bot a prototype
and i need me that bit of high grade
military tip
because if we don't get that body we
don't get no soccer chip
and we sure as hell don't get no happily
ever after
but don't get excited it's a single-use
toy
now i slide out purchase the damn thing
from maelstrom
problem is i did so from a gentleman by
the name of brick
i say win because brick was the leader
three days after we'd sealed our deal
his friend and gang mate one simon
randle aka royce
playing dropped his ass royce is in
charge now
and i got no way of knowing if he aims
to honor his predecessor's word
one meredith stout of militech has
developed an interest in said convoy
i think i got everything time i got to
work
well that's just music to my ears that's
a friendly fella
one more thing
[Music]
quiet life or blaze of glory
blaze of glory
i like that guy i like the characters
this game creates
i'm not so much for the shooting and the
grand theft auto style quest but
like i like the city
i like the people
if you suspect any rogue ai activity
call the hotline immediately oh my god
i love this world hey so
how you want to play this bell strummer
parker was first
let's visit maelstrom can we knock on
maelstrom's door first
pound actually we'll take care of that
situation
in that case and call it
as i'm playing this now i'm realizing
how much i've
changed relative to my ability to
appreciate
a grand theft auto style game
not loving it let me hear what you
squared away
let's meet him dex already paid the mail
streamers for the corporal bot
thing is can't be sure the gang goons
are still willing to hand it over
he paid up front
well whatever let's go get this tech
don't know you
want to talk to royce dex sent us
we've been waiting
i've ever seen security like this in the
shower factory lots of books just laying
around
call them special all right
let's meet this fella get in the
elevator
stay cool they're just trying to spook
us
remember we're on their turf 21.
you got a bot model mt-0d12
called the flathead this is gonna be a
lot of combat
the hell you care guy i represent
already paid brick for it
i'm just here for the pickup i can talk
direct to royce if necessary
now you talk to me name's tomtom
now couch planet
[Music]
i like these couches they got uh
character reminds me of true romance
that scene with uh drexels for youtube
i'll stand
they're so [ __ ] hard [ __ ] ass
on the [ __ ] couch make me
thought you'd never ask
see your ass down for a planet bullet
you scum
jack sit down
this ain't to end well but
[ __ ] well
all right
come on got lined up take a hit
yeah you gotta wonder with all that
neurotech what kind of drugs they do
what is with this guy here we go
the flat head model mp0
need to see it this is
this is like a spot what's the dynamic
spot robot
oh it's the robot dog in it this is
awesome dynamic
thermal yes cognitive immersion with a
raven controller
pimped out prototype actuators made of
titanium vanadium kevlar composite
and watch this fully
integrated link too so when the spider
starts crawling up walls dangling from
ceilings
could lose your lunch where am i
supposed to look
we'll take it yep we'll take it
free sure yeah
let's see brick got it it's all paid up
i don't see any [ __ ] brick around
here do you
there's a lot of swearing in this game
[Music]
dexter desean that's
dexter deshawn the hard ass who punching
animal [ __ ] out of a pacifica all
right
nope he's alive
ah boy let's shoot them
grab the gear
[Music]
oh gotta grab the robot i almost forgot
got the set bot and controller
the quicker the better all right
looking at the time i gotta escape this
place
i'm sure that would be very much fun but
um
i gotta get back to work at uh about an
hour or more before i head to bed so
this is really fun to escape but mostly
it was fun to play games again
i would say this is kind of like a grand
theft auto with an rpg
flavor to it i think a lot of people
really enjoy this game it's not really
my thing
i'd love to explore this world in a
different kind of context
there's a little bit too much shooting
for my tastes
uh if i'm gonna do shooting i'd rather
do just a straight up
shooter like i like call of duty all
that kind of stuff this was a cool game
but i'm gonna walk away with a smile
and some good memories sadly i didn't
get to meet keanu ruiz's character
but uh life is full of disappointments
as david goggins said recently on his
instagram
when uh life gives you lemons just
eat the mother effing lemons
so i hope there wasn't too much swearing
or nudity in this game that was kind of
uh
a shock to me a little bit definitely
haven't played a game like it before
maybe like duke nukem was the last game
that had that kind of uh
flavor to it anyway this is uh
a first time i played a video game in
quite a long time
and definitely obviously the first time
i've ever recorded myself playing a
video game so
this is just a one giant experiment let
me know what you think
if it's of interest to anyone i'll play
another video game
maybe close to new year's and try to do
it once a month but like i said
2021 is going to be a hell of a crazy
year
this was a lot of fun if you have time
on your hands you should definitely play
this game
if not they should get your butt back to
work
and again uh thanks for our two sponsors
there gun
and grammarly like i said ones for the
muscles one for your grammar
pick the one you want to work on most or
do both and check them out in the
description to get a discount
and to support the podcast i host hope
this was at all
enjoyable let me know what other games
you'd like to see me play
in the distant future and i encourage
all of you to play this or other video
games if it's a source of joy
life's too short not to do all these
kinds of
fun little detours love you all happy
holidays
you